[Music]
are you a fan of mecha suits and robotic
armors
well here in this video we will present
to you guys the seven biggest iron man
armors these giant armors have been
designed for specific purposes
a couple of them are not really created
by tony stark but used by him for quite
a while during his battles against truly
gigantic enemies so subscribe if you
haven't and now let's get on with this
list
at number 7 we have the hulk buster
yes the smallest on this list is the
mark
xliv armor better known as the hulk
buster it was tony stark's 44th iron man
suit made with the help of bruce banner
the suit was specifically designed to
match the incredible superhuman strength
of the hulk and is powered by over 11
arc reactors in order to grant the
strength required for such a task
this one and the second version seen in
infinity war were both around 11 feet
tall or 3.35 meters it was bulky and
modular as damaged parts can be replaced
in the battlefield
on number 6 we have the phoenix killer
armor seen in issue 5 of avengers vs
x-men this was an armor designed by tony
stark when he found out that the phoenix
force was on approach towards earth it
was created with the aim to either
contain or at the most kill the cosmic
force this armor was created by tony
stark and hank pym in the end was able
to destroy the phoenix force
theoretically making the armor and tony
stark to be among the strongest marvel
characters in the comics just under the
cosmic entities this armor was seen to
be around 40 to 50 feet or 12 to 15
meters tall
number five the finn fang film buster
seen in issue one of tony stark iron man
and known officially as model 57 the
thing fan film buster was created by
stark to specifically fight against a
mclaren dragon known as fing fang fume
an alien creature that can fly at
supersonic speeds and has a very high
intellect super strength durability
telepathy and can spew acid from his
mouth although it was designed to fight
off the dragon it was critically damaged
and failed to do so the mark 57 was 20
stories high which means around 200 to
220 feet or 61 to 67 meters tall
number 4 the celestial extremia during
the apocalyptic events of king in black
one of the symbiote dragons brought in
by the symbiote god null during his
invasion of earth was targeted by iron
man using the extremist techno-organic
virus tony attempted to rewrite the
symbiote's dna and to sever its
connection from null's hive in the
process of subduing the symbiote the
creature infused itself into iron man's
armor and became the extremit armor and
with this iron man was able to take over
even a re-animated celestial and pilot
it remotely and as we all know
celestials are enormous reaching over
2000 feet or 610 meters tall
number three the god killer armor mark
ii designed by tony stark the god killer
armor mark ii was a celestial size armor
based on the original god killer armor
created eons ago by the aspirants
the armor was kept in standby orbiting
mars the mark ii when the dark
celestials attacked earth iron man
deployed the god killer armor mark ii
and it allowed him to hold his own
against the dark celestials for a
limited period of time
and like the previous entry we can
estimate the size of the armor to be
about the same as the celestial so
putting it around 2000 feet or 610
meters tall
number two the god killer armor although
this isn't one that was created by tony
stark he did however fuse with it for
quite some time the god killer armor was
designed and used by the aspirants
billions of years ago in order to fight
against the celestials in the celestial
war this armor did manage to slay quite
a few of these space guards but in the
end was decommissioned for spare parts
and was stored in a dyson sphere for
eons a sentient robot in the present
called 451 took tony stark to the god
killer armor and forced them to unite
and fused them together and although
they were incompatible this monstrous
armor was used by tony stark for quite a
while and its size was enormous around
25 000 feet or 7.6 kilometers tall
and number one
the iron god in his latest appearance in
the comics iron man was imbued with the
power cosmic and now has unlimited power
and abilities firstly he chooses to have
an armor that has got like an appearance
it has a silver texture to it and has
red fiery eyes as well as red glowing
energy arc reactors in this form iron
man can choose whatever size he wants to
be with whatever suits the situation in
his fight with kovac another being that
was imbued with the power cosmic they
both grow to be absolutely cosmic in
scale as one can see them smashing
entire planets onto each other's faces
this is the biggest form ever of iron
man
anyway with that we come to the end of
the video so hit that like button for
support subscribe and also smash that
bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam